7만원에 파시고 21만원에 다시 사셨다는 얘기를 듣고 물어봤더니 진짜 아무것도 모른다고 생각하시라고
그건 알아요 PER
Price, Earning, Rat Deal
좀 비주얼이 증권가 이런 춤도 있는 엘리트들이 모인 자리 약간 품격 있고 그런 느낌이 좀 들어요 뭐 슈카친구들 느낌도 좀 나고
자 그럼 들어가보도록 하겠습니다. 안녕하세요. 침착맨입니다. 제가 최근에 주식으로 인해서 잠시 화제가 된 적이 있었습니다. 사실 주식에 대한 지식이 그렇게 대단하지는 않거든요. 일반인 아래에요. 그래서 오늘 이거에 대해서 좀 배워보고자 아주 특별한 분 모셨습니다. 자기소개 한 번씩 부탁드리도록 하겠습니다.
네. 안녕하세요. 저는 토스증권 리서치센터에서 애널리스트로 근무하고 있는 한상원입니다.
아 네. 반갑습니다.
안녕하세요. 저는 토스증권에서 AI 콘텐츠 서비스 담당하고 있는 이혜인이라고 합니다. 반갑습니다.
제가 토스증권은 평상시에 많이 이용하거든요. 일단 편해요. 근데 막 이제 사람들이 다른 거 쓰는 분들도 많더라고요. 아무래도 나온 지가 오래 안 돼서 그런가?
그쵸. 아마.
말을 굉장히 아끼시네요.
개인적으로 하시면 할 말 많으신 것 같습니다.
그런데 안 쓰는 분들도 있잖아요. 아니 뭐 전율이 100%인 그런 서비스는 없잖아요.
그렇죠. 그렇죠. 그렇죠.
안 쓰는 사람도 있더라고요. 그 이유가 나온 지가 얼마 안 돼서 그런 건가? 아무래도 자기 쓰던 거 계속 쓰잖아요.
저희 전문용어로 락인이라 그러죠. 내가 쓰던 거에 편해가지고 믿겨버려가지고 거기에.
아. 락인 두 글자 때문에 품격이 또 올라가죠.
품격. 품격.
오늘 왜 이렇게 품격이 올라가는 거야?
알겠습니다. 그럼 한상원님은 애널리스트라고 하셨는데 제가 한 몇 년 전만 해도 애널리스트가 뭔지를 잘 몰랐어요.
오. 이제는 아시나요?
주식 샀다, 팔았다.
사팔사팔 하시는 분 아니에요?
아니에요.
아니에요?
아닙니다.
죄송합니다.
증권사 리포트.
아. 분석하시고.
네. 맞습니다. 그래서.
사고 팔지는 않으세요?
사고 팔지는 않고.
그럼 누가 사고 팔아요?
사고 파는 거는 펀드매니저라고 하는 자금을 모아서 운용하시는 분들께서.
이혜인 님은 AI 무슨 관련.
저는 이제 콘텐츠 쪽 맡고 있는 상황이긴 합니다.
콘텐츠.
네. 네. AI 콘텐츠.
AI로 어떻게 콘텐츠를.
작곡?
작곡요?
작곡.
작곡?
제가 최근에 AI로 작곡을. 작사를 했었거든요.
좋더라고요.
그렇죠.
들으셨어요?
네.
나중에 파일 보내드릴게요.
저희는 시장에 되게 많은 투자 정보들이 있잖아요. AI가 그런 걸 요약도 잘하고 콘텐츠도 예쁘게 만들 수 있잖아요.
그래서 그런 거에 AI를 지금 활용하고 있다라고 보시면 돼요.
그러면 이제 이 전문가 두 분을 모셔놓고 오늘 뭐 할 거냐면 좀 특강을 들어볼 생각이에요.
제가 주식을 너무 모르기 때문에. 혹시 전에 주식 영상들 보신 적 있나요?
네.
어떤 영상을 보셨나요?
제가 샀습니다.
아.
3전.
약간 이슈가 됐었거든요.
그러더라고요.
제가 7만에 팔아서 21만에 다시 샀어요. 3전자를.
그리고 나서 가격이 좀 많이 떨어지더라고요. 그래서 그다음부터 아 주식 공부해야겠다.
사실 순서가 공부하고 들어가야 되는데 들어가고 아 맞다. 이렇게 되면 안 되겠다. 공부를 해야겠다.
근데 놀라운 거는 아 공부해야겠다 했는데 아 까만 건 글자인데 이거 하얀 건 뭐야. 막 이렇게 하다가 흥미가 급속도로 떨어지더라고요.
근데 마침 토스 증권에서 뭐 알아보는 시간 한 번 가져보면 어떠냐 해서 세상 아니 광고를 하면서 배울 수 있다고? 전문가 분이 두 분이 나오셔서 말이 안 되잖아요.
이번 기회에 시청자 여러분들도 좀 배우시면 좀 좋을 것 같아서 자리를 좀 만들어 봤습니다.
PPT를 좀 준비해 주셨다고요?
네.
7만 원에 파시고 21만 원에 다시 사셨다는 얘기를 듣고 침착맨 님께 알려줬으면 좋겠다라고 하셔가지고 제가 준비를 했는데 이거 어떻게 준비해야 될지 모르겠는 거예요.
제가 침착맨 님이 어느 정도인지 알아야.
이거 맞춰서 준비를 할 거잖아요. 물어봤더니 진짜 아무것도 모른다고 생각하시라고.
그거는 알아요. PER.
Price. Earning. Ratio.
배웠어요. 슈카 님한테.
총 그거죠. Price. 가격. 주식 다 합친 거. Earning. 순이익. Ratio. 비율. 이런 느낌.
중요하잖아.
진짜. 진짜.
가장 간단한 게 뭡니까? PER이 7이다. 자산까지 가는데 7년 걸린다. 단순히.
단순하게.
어떤 이런 느낌? 날까?
잠깐만. 이거 너무 쉽게 준비해야 되는데.
그러게요. 그러게요. 너무 지금.
그래요.
한 번 그래도 들어보시죠. 제가 그래서 조금 쉽게 설명드리려고 한 번 준비를 해봤고.
알겠습니다.
그래서 이런 말씀을 하셨다라고 하더라고요.
그런데 이제 그 이후로 결론적으로는 안 하셨다.
맞아요.
아직도 디렘이 뭔지 몰라요.
그래서 오늘부터 이제 삼성전자 투자를 위한 기초적인 내용들을 한 번 설명을 드려볼까 하는데요.
네.
그리고 그 이후의 말씀.
저는 일단 무당이 아닙니다.
그렇죠.
그리고 주식에는 100%가 없습니다.
오늘 제 얘기를 들으셨다고.
김창민 님도 무조건 앞으로 수익을 낼 거다.
주가의 오르내림을 다 맞출 거다.
이런 욕심이 일단 말이 안 된다.
이걸 하나 알아주셨으면 좋겠고.
제가 이제 반도체 얘기를 아무래도 할 수밖에 없는데.
제가 반도체 박사는 아니에요.
전체적으로 공부를 할 뿐이지.
그렇죠. 그런데 이제 반도체 투자를 하려면 반도체에 대한 엄청난 지식을 알아야만 투자를 한다면 그럼 또 저희가 투자를 하기 위한 허들이 너무 높잖아요.
그래서 꼭 그렇지 않아도 된다.
반도체 산업에.
혹은 반도체 관련 기업들에 투자를 할 수 있을 정도의 아주 기초적인.
이 정도만 아셔도 투자할 수 있습니다.
이렇게 준비를 해왔으니까.
투자를 업으로 하고 있는 애널리스트라는 관점에서 오늘의 이야기를 말씀드린다고 봐주시면 좋을 것 같고.
그래서 팀에서 학습 목표를 이렇게 적어주셨더라고요.
네.
제가 봤을 때는 좀 어려울 것 같고.
이렇게 하기로 하겠습니다.
앞표가 뭐였죠?
잠깐 봐도 될까요?
네.
삼성전자가 왜 투자했는지 스스로 설명할 수 있다.
삼성전자의 주가 변화를 스스로 설명할 수 있다.
무지성을 올라타고 구조적으로 요청하지 않는 상태로 만들어야 되는데.
이건 좀 쉽죠.
핵심은 이겁니다.
맞아요.
이게 중요해요.
그렇죠.
저는 항상 기다려요.
네.
왕자님을.
근데 구조가 되신 거잖아요.
근데 안 타요.
그 백마에.
그게 문제예요.
그리고 또 기다려요.
또 안 타요.
그러다가 나중에 뭐 하냐면 헌신이 생겨서 짚신 신고 나가요.
그래서 오늘 목표는 누군가에게 투자 판단을 의지하기보다는 조금 스스로 생각해보실 수 있는 거를 목표로 해보겠습니다.
알겠습니다.
오늘 이제 구조도 안 부르려면 제가 생각했을 때 그냥 기초적인 키워드는 이거죠.
두 개거든요.
반도체랑 사이클.
사이클.
그래서 반도체가 무엇이냐.
반도체 공부하셨나요.
찾아보셨나요.
제가 아는 거는 도체.
오케이.
그러니까 반절이에요.
와다리가다리 하는 그 미묘한 녀석이기 때문에 이걸 신호로 해가지고 하는 거잖아요.
오 맞습니다.
맞습니다.
찾아보니까 이렇게 나오더라고요.
근데 제가 생각했을 땐 이거를 도체랑 부도체에 집중하는 순간 머리가 아파지는 거 같거든요.
아.
보통 투자할 때 어떤 기업들이 있으면 이 기업들이 하는 일에 저희가 일상생활에 편한 데로 끌어올 수가 있어요.
그래서 제 생각에는 여기서 키워드를 도체, 부도체도 당연히 너무 중요한 이야기지만 저는 컴퓨팅이라고 생각했습니다.
컴퓨팅이라는 거는 결국에는 계산을 한다는 거잖아요.
인간으로 치면 뇌에 해당한다.
전자기기들의 뇌에 해당하는 것이 반도체다.
그러면 저는 반도체 다 알았다.
끝나버렸네요.
반도체 공부는.
반도체는 끝났고 하나 조금 더 내려가 보면 디렘.
그래서 디렘은 무엇인가.
디렘은 우리나라가 잘하는 거.
그렇죠.
근데 진짜로.
대만은 딴 거 한다고.
오.
들었어요.
생각보다 뭘 많이 보시네요.
진짜 전혀 모르실 거라고 해서.
삼성전자 때문에.
삼성전자가 저를 이렇게 많이 봤어요.
어쨌든 결론적으로 디렘은 반도체의 종류입니다.
인간으로 치면 뇌잖아요.
뇌도 이제 여러 개.
복잡하신 거예요.
네.
죄송합니다.
갑자기 계속 복잡해졌어요.
메모리, 비메모리 이거 두 개만 기억해 주시고.
디렘하고 랜드 이렇게 두 개만 기억해 주시면 돼요.
메모리는 기억하는 뇌.
비메모리는 생각하는 뇌.
메모리 같은 경우는 기억하는 뇌도 잠깐 기억하는 거 있잖아요.
인증번호 같은 거 두 자릿수.
이런 거는 저희가 머리에 잠깐 기억했다가 하고 나면 까먹잖아요.
이런 잠깐 기억하는 게 디렘.
반도체로 치면.
그리고 좀 오래 시험 공부를 한다든가.
이건 외워야지 해서 기억하고 있는 거는 랜드.
이렇게 이해를 하시면.
인간의 뇌는 저희가 잠깐 기억하고 싶다고 사실 잠깐 기억하고
오래 기억해야지라고 오래 기억할 수 있지는 않잖아요.
누구나 암기과목 시험 잘 볼 테니까.
컴퓨터는 그게 가능한 게 저희가 저장 버튼.
Ctrl S라는 저장 버튼을 누르면 랜드로 넘어가고.
컴퓨터 꺼지면 막 날아갔다.
이런 거는 그게 디렘에 있었기 때문에.
그렇게 이해를 하시면 됩니다.
사실 저는.
옛날부터 컴퓨터 게임을 많이 해가지고.
좀 친숙하긴 해요.
컴퓨터 저장 안 하면서 실시간 하는 거.
디렘.
저장하는 거.
랜드.
블래쉬.
너무 쉽죠.
투자 준비 다 됐습니다.
그러게요.
너무.
앞부분은 그냥 빨리빨리 가겠습니다.
그래서 이제 반도체 얘기.
삼성전자 얘기를 하면.
워낙 갤럭시 많은 분들이 쓰시니까.
삼성전자 반도체 말고 다른 것도 있는데.
그런 것도 중요하지 않아.
이런 얘기를 하시거든요.
제가 이제 여쭤보고 싶은 거는.
저희가 투자할 때 가장 뭐가 중요할까.
객관식으로 혹시 어려우실까 봐.
여기서 고르면 돼요?
그렇죠.
투자할 때는.
이익.
이익 어려운 문제.
이익 아니에요?
맞습니다.
어떻게 이걸 내가 이익을 골랐지.
진짜.
이익 어려운 문제.
엄청 많은데.
팔찌 선다인데.
이게 매 주식 투자할 때 이익이 중요하냐면.
실제로 삼성전자의 주가랑 영업이익 흐름을 제가 이렇게 그려봤거든요.
보시면 파란색 선이 이익인데.
이익이 높아질 때 주가도 높아지고.
이익이 낮아질 때 주가도 높아지고.
낮아지거든요.
그래서 대체로 이익이 높은 시기에 주가도 높고.
낮은 시기에 주가도 낮으니까.
당연히 저희는 이익을 잘 트래킹해야겠죠.
그럼 삼성전자의 이익이 어떻게 구성되어 있는지를 보면.
이렇게 구성되어 있습니다.
물론 여러 사업부들이 있지만.
아무래도 작년 기준으로 봤을 때는.
반도체가 워낙 이익에서 큰 부분을 차지하고 있고.
조금 더 핵심은.
어느 사업부에서 이익을 많이 번다 보다.
어느 사업부에서 이익이 많이 났다.
조금 났다를 반복하느냐를 봐야 되거든요.
그렇게 봤을 때에는.
이렇게 됩니다.
반도체와 반도체 외 사업부.
이렇게 나눠서 봤을 때.
반도체 외 사업부는 대략으로 봤을 때.
10조에서 20조.
이렇게 가죠.
사실 10조라는 돈은 굉장히 큰 돈이죠.
하지만 반도체 사업이라는 게.
마이너스 10조가 넘었다가.
플러스 50조가 났다가 이러니까.
삼성전자 이런 이익의 변동성을 만드는 주된 이유가.
반도체다.
그래서 삼성전자를 볼 때는.
저희가 반도체를 중심으로 보고.
제가 시작하자마자 반도체 얘기를 꺼낸 것도.
이 때문이었다.
이렇게 보시면 됩니다.
끝났습니다.
반도체는.
반도체 벌써 공부해버렸다.
네.
5분 만에.
두 번째 키워드로.
사이클로 넘어가겠습니다.
네.
사이클.
돈다는 거지.
오.
사이클이 돌잖아요.
바퀴가.
아니야?
맞아요.
그런데 제가 지금 말씀드리려는.
사이클이 뭐냐면.
위아래가 극명한 산업에 대해서.
얘기를 하려고 했거든요.
네.
그런데 어원이 같아요.
이 사이클이랑.
이 사이클이 이렇게 도는 거니까.
위아래를 왔다 갔다 하는 거니까.
이게 개그로만 넣은 건 아니고.
아.
그래서 이제 국내 업체에 대한.
메모리 반도체가.
특히 대표적인 사이클 산업이라고.
저희가 얘기를 하는데.
앞서 보여드린.
이익으로 보시면.
이게 이익은 그래도.
꾸준히 좀 늘어나기 때문에.
이걸 위아래를.
정확히 보기가 어려워서.
이거를 제가.
영업이익률이라는.
지표로 가져왔거든요.
네.
쉽게 말하면.
매출을 100 거두면.
그 중에.
몇 퍼센트가 남는가.
이런 지표예요.
보시면.
마이너스 몇 십 퍼센트도 갔다가.
위로.
플러스 몇 십 퍼센트도 가거든요.
그만큼.
이렇게 위아래 사이클이.
반복되는 것이.
메모리 반도체 산업이다.
그런데.
마이너스 20%까지 갔을 때.
있잖아요.
네.
마이너스 20%까지 찍으면.
왜냐하면 저.
홈은.
그렇죠.
확언할 수는 없죠.
과거에 그냥.
그랬다라는 거고.
마이너스 20 가기 전에.
올라갈 수도 있고.
그런 거죠.
그런데.
20% 가기 전에.
올라갈 수도 있지만.
20%로 가면.
웬만하면 올라가네요.
이것만 봤을 땐.
사실은.
이거 관련해서는.
뒷 내용들이 좀 있어서.
시간이.
이거 심화로 넘겨서.
왜 이렇게 궁금한 게 많지.
근데.
생각보다 많이 하셔서.
좀 당황하시는데.
그러면.
이 사이클이라는 것이.
왜 생기느냐.
이렇게 보면.
공장이 있어야 되잖아요.
네.
공장을 짓는 데.
시간이 필요하단 말이죠.
당연히 돈도 많이 필요하고.
그러면 이제.
수요가 좋아요.
빨간색 선이 수요입니다.
수요가 막.
너무 좋아가지고.
공급은 부족하고.
반도체 좀 더 만들어줘.
라고 했을 때.
그러면 내가 공장을 질게.
라고 합니다.
공장을 짓는 기간 동안은.
생산량이 크게 안 늘어나죠.
그렇죠.
짓는 순간에.
이게 싹 늘어나거든요.
그럼 그때부터는.
다시 공급이 많아집니다.
수요는 그만큼 많지는 않은데.
가 반복돼요.
그래서.
이런 거예요.
진짜요.
공장 지었어.
줄게.
나 지금.
그 정도는 필요 없는데.
거의.
빙의되셨어.
많이 만들었다고.
네.
보통 공장 짓는 데.
한 3년 정도 걸리기 때문에.
실제 반도체.
이 사이클.
3년을 주기로.
왔다 갔다.
하거든요.
계속 그렇게.
아.
네가 필요할 텐데.
힘들었는데.
네.
이런 이유들 때문에.
그리고 사이클이.
반복된다.
그래서.
수요와 공급이.
정확히 만나기가.
어렵습니다.
어느 때는.
수요가 많았다가.
공급이 많았다가.
하고.
이걸 실제로 보면.
일을 기준으로.
위에 있으면.
수요가 많은 거거든요.
아래에 있으면.
공급이 많고.
위에 있으면.
수요가 더 많은 거니까.
반도체가 모자란다는 뜻이고.
가격도 막 오르겠죠.
밑에 있으면.
반도체가 남는 거니까.
가격도 막 떨어지고.
그런 거겠죠.
그럴 때.
그럼 기업들의 이익은.
아래에 있을 때가.
수급 밸런스가.
아래에 있을 때 좋다.
나쁘다.
맞습니다.
그래서 앞서 보여드린.
영업이익률.
그걸 같이 그려보면.
이렇게.
그림이 나옵니다.
공급이 많은 거구나.
아래에 있을 때.
네.
맞아요.
벌어 들이는 돈이 많고.
그래서 공급이 많을 때는.
당연히.
기업들이 벌어 들이는.
이직
투자보다는 오히려 이럴 때는 조금 길게 왜냐면 반도체 사이클이라는 게 있으니까 2, 3년의 기간을 보고 투자 판단을 하시고
불황했을 때 사고, 포항일 때 팔고 이런 전략들 투자 전략으로 사이클 산업에서는 가져가시면 유리하고요. 그래서 실제로 만약에 이렇게 투자를 했으면
먹혔을까? 실제 삼성전자 주가를 그려보면 이렇게 나옵니다. 밑에가 삼성전자 주가거든요. 그래서 사고, 팔고, 사고, 팔고, 사고
위에 사이클을 보고 투자를 했다면 이런 것들을 팔 수가 있다. 근데 왜 저 오른쪽을 갑자기 발작을 일으켜요?
발작을 왜 일으키나 봐요? 대체? 파셨죠? 제가 파셨죠? 그것도 제가 뒤에 있습니다. 설명을 드릴게요.
어쨌든 그런데 이게 이렇게 보면 그냥 너무 쉬워 보일까봐 제가 조금 부연 설명을 드리면은 맨 밑에 축이 연도에요. 그래서 맨 앞에 저 때에 만약에 매수를 한다면
한 1년 정도 큰 재미 없습니다. 주가가 밑으로 내리기도 하고요. 그래서 내가 정확한 고점과 저점을 맞추겠다 라는
생각도 들어요. 그래서 내가 정확한 고점과 저점을 맞추겠다 라는 생각도 들어요. 그래서 내가 정확한 고점과 저점을 맞추겠다 라는 생각도 들어요. 그래서 내가 정확한 고점과 저점을 맞추겠다 라는 생각을
하시면 당연히 안되고 나는 저점 부분에서 살고 고점 부분에서 팔 거니까 저점 쯤이라고 생각되면 그때부터 그냥 사 모으고 고점 쯤이라고 생각되면 팔고 이런 식으로 조금 접근을 하시는 것이 투자 전략으로서는 사이클 산업에서 유용할 수 있다.
아 그렇구나. 저는 종토방 같은데 3전을 왜 사냐? 지금 같은 불장에 3전을 사는 머저리가 있어? 딴 거 사야지 오르지도 않고 떨어지도 않는 거 이거 왜 사는 거야? 근데 이거는 사이클에 준해서 해야 돼.
그쵸 그쵸. 오히려 아까 말씀드렸던 저런 시기들이 그런 시기일 수 있어요. 나는 이제 저런 걸 보고 투자를 했는데 굉장히 조롱받고 있는 그런 상황일 수 있어요. 사실 이렇게 투자하는 것도 저도 이렇게 가지고는 왔지만 그렇게 실천한다는 것이 쉽지 않기는 합니다. 어쨌든 이렇게 하시면 되고. 실제로 삼성전자를 언제 사셨다고 하셨죠?
제가 9만 때 샀어요. 10만 간다 뭐 한다.
아 그럼 21년 초 때네요.
네.
그러면은 이렇게 하신 거거든요.
근데 매도를 할 때 꾸준히 샀어요. 물을 계속 타서 사실은 평단이.
매도에 살짝 아래에 있어요.
그래서 신나서 팔았죠.
그러면 왕자님 백마에 타신 거네요? 구조대에.
집신 신고 나간 거죠.
아 집신 신고 나간 거죠.
왕자님 발이 뒤에 오는데 안 타고 집신 신고 그냥 제가 스스로 나갔어요.
그래서 10% 정도 먹고 나갔어요.
근데 문제는 그거예요.
아 근데 왜 너 먹었는데 왜 자꾸 투달돼? 이럴 수 있잖아요.
그렇게 해서 탈출한 걸로 다른 걸 들어갔거든요. 전체가 무너졌어요.
그리고 3전은 오르고 그래서 다 말아먹었어요.
한 반절 빠졌나.
10% 먹고 히히 나가고 딴 데 넣었다가 반절 빠졌나.
그래서 이런 사이클 산업에서는 이런 투자를 해야 되는데
정반대에 투자를 좀 하신 것 같다.
이게 제일 가슴이 아프죠.
여기서 샀어요.
여기 있다고 하더라고요. 대충 축을 계산해보면.
지금 그런 상황이고.
최근 삼성전자 얘기 들어보셨어요?
최근 삼성전자 젠슨 형하고 치킨 먹지 않았어요?
삼성전자가 먹은 건 아니고 어떤.
어쨌든 제가 말씀드리고 싶은 거는 이익 얘기를 많이 했으니까.
삼성전자 이익 관련된 뉴스.
이익 관련된 뉴스가 나왔다는 사실을 알고 계신 거예요.
엄청난 이익이 났다는 소문이 막 돌더라고요.
맞습니다.
그리고 하이닉스 직원들이 퇴사를 안 한다.
그것까지 봤어요.
열심히 일한다.
삼성전자가 지금 사상 최대의 이익을 거뒀다라는 얘기들이 뉴스에 나오거든요.
글로벌 빅테크들이랑 비교해도 진짜 견줄만한 실적 수준이다.
왜 이익이 좋느냐.
이게 지금 제가 대표적으로 아까 말했던 메모리 반도체 가격 가지고 온 건데.
가격이 지금 엄청나게 오르잖아요.
가격이 오르면은 기업들은 내가 만드는 데 들어가는 돈이 크게 안 변했는데.
그렇죠.
사는 가격이 확 오른 거잖아요.
그래서 벌어들이는 이익이 막대하게 커졌다.
삼성전자의 이번 1분기 실적은 사실 조금 앞서서 4월 초에 공시가 됐고요.
그걸 보면 57조라는 사상 최대 실적을 거뒀고.
제가 이런 게 좀 있더라고요.
이 짤 어디서 나시나요.
저보다 짤이 많아요.
짧으세요 짧으세요.
아니 저보다 제 짤이 많아요.
아니 진짜 대단하세요.
이거 이런 거 적재적재 어떻게 쓰시는 거지.
어떻게 이렇게.
팀원분들이 도와주셨습니다.
그래요.
주식 투자하는 사람들 종토방 가면 맨날 침팬치가 막.
아.
막 이러잖아요.
그 침팬치 표정인데.
그래서 이런 얘기 봤어요.
그 침방뿔 얘기 있잖아요.
삼성전자를 파시면 주가가 막 오르고 사면 떨어진다.
저는 약간 축소된 해석이다.
사실은 글로벌 메모리 반도체 사이클을 움직였다.
오히려 더 큰 영향을.
네 영향력을 사람들이 계속 평가하고 있다.
지금 저 매도하신 이유로 반도체 가격들이 정말로 엄청난.
이런 적이 없었잖아요 사실.
사실은 정말 유례없는 호황이라고.
그러니까요.
실적이 좋은 상황이거든요.
그래서 삼성전자뿐만이 아니라 국내 반도체 기업들.
해외 반도체 기업들도 다 지금 엄청난 수혜를.
심창민 님 덕분에.
치킨에 뭣 얻나?
왜 이렇게 되는 거야.
진짜 어이가 없어.
제가 지금까지 어찌됐든 정리해보면 사이클 산업에 투자를 말씀을 드렸잖아요.
근데 지금 삼성전자 실적이 이미 잘 나왔잖아요.
그러면 제가 말했던 사이클 산업 안 좋을 때 사야 되는 전략은 지금 쓸 수가 없단 말이에요.
그러면 다음 안 좋을 때를 기다려야 되니까.
지금 상황에서는 그냥 저희가 호황은 시작됐다라고 보고.
이 호황이 언제까지 갈까.
이런 걸 고민해야 되거든요.
저희가 좋다는 건 알지만 이게 좋아진 게 이제 초입인지.
중간쯤 맞는지.
끝나가는 건지.
끝난 건지.
이런 거는 알 수 없잖아요.
혹자는 이번엔 사이클이라는 게 없어졌다.
쭉 간다.
이렇게 말씀하시는 분들도 있거든요.
저희는 그걸 알 수 없으니까.
사실은 지금부터의 투자는 많은 정보들을 조금 신경 쓰고 예민하게 바라봐야 되고.
난이도도 사실은 조금 올라간 것이 맞다.
이렇게 봐주시면 되고.
어쨌든 결론적으로는 저희는 이 고점이 언제일지 몰라요.
모른다는 걸 그냥 받아들이고.
이 고점이 사이클의 호황이 끝나간다라는.
신호를 어떤 지표들을 혹은 정보들을 잘 종합해서 받아들일 수 있어야 되는 것이 중요한 시점이거든요.
그런 걸 알려면 결론적으로 지금 왜 좋은지를 알아야 되잖아요.
이게 실제로 이 앞에 보여드렸던 영업잉률 기준으로 사이클 가져온 거거든요.
혹시 과거 사례 중에 지금과 조금 비슷하다고 느껴지시는.
비대면.
왜요?
3년 전에 샀어요.
비대면에.
제가 그러니까 사이클 있잖아요. 3년 사이클.
그때 항상 올랐을 때 사고 떨어졌을 때 열심히 물 타고.
제가 아침 창매님 기준으로.
비대면 때 사고 AI 때 사고.
봉우리 때만 샀어요.
아직은 봉우리인지 몰라요.
그렇죠. 아직 모르죠.
AI는 모릅니다.
위로 갈 테 아래로 갈 테.
저희는 이제 그런 것들을 잘 살펴보자.
이런 거고.
정확하게 얘기하자면 PC, 스마트폰.
비대면 때라는 거는 저희가 이제 다 집에 들어앉아서 노트북 뭐 이런 거 다 바꿀 때잖아요.
그래서 최종 수요가 소비자이거든요.
그러면 소비자는 어떤 특징이 있냐면 반도체 가격이 막 올라간다고 했을 때.
스마트폰 가격이 막 올라가면 사기가 점점 부담스러워지잖아요.
안 사요.
그런데 지금 사이클은 사실 클라우드랑 비슷하거든요.
저때도 기업들이 투자를 막 하면서 반도체가 더 많이 필요했던 시기예요.
그런데 기업들의 특징은 뭐냐면 소비자에 비해서 가격 민감도가 조금 많습니다.
그 말은 가격이 조금 올라도 그냥 잘 사가고.
왜냐하면 지금으로 생각해보면 사활을 걸고 있잖아요.
그런 차이가 있다고 보시면 돼요.
그래서 어떤 일이 나타나냐면 고점이 높습니다.
그래서 지금 사이클은 일단 그런 사이클.
기업들이 투자하는 사이클이고 AI 때문이다 이렇게 보시면 되고.
네.
AI에서.
그럼 가장 중요한 키워드가 HBM이거든요.
혹시 HBM은 들어보시나요?
이건 모르겠어요.
HBM.
좋습니다.
제가 아까 D램 말씀드렸잖아요.
고성능 D램.
이 정도만 아시면 됩니다.
이게 AI로 치면 기존 반도체들은 저렇게 가운데 GPU 생각하는 데 바깥에 기억하는 데가 깔려 있잖아요.
그런데 이게 기억하는 데로부터 거리가 좀 멀죠.
그리고 길도 그냥 각각 하나씩 있다고 가정을 하면 필요한 데이터가 이렇게 제때제때 못 가는 거예요.
그럼 이런 렉을 먹는 거예요.
말을 하다가.
뭐 말하려고 그랬지?
제가 자주 그래요.
아.
생각하는 데도 뺑뺑이 안 돌지 않습니까?
네.
전체적으로.
어쨌든 그런 상황이거든요.
그래서 이걸 어떻게 바꾼 거냐면 기억하는 뇌들을 쌓아 올리고 생각하는 뇌에 가까이 붙인 겁니다.
그래서 데이터들이 훨씬 더 빠르게 확 더 많은 양이 왔다 갔다 할 수 있도록 그렇게 했다라고 예를 해주시면 되고.
AI가 될수록 이제 저런 것들이 필요하잖아요.
저 AI 쓰면 굉장히 많은 데이터를 처리를 하는 거잖아요.
그래서 이 HBM이 굉장히 AI 투자 사이클 초기에 주목을 받았던.
램으로 구룡성체를 만들었네요.
그렇죠.
디램의 일종인데.
그래서 이것들이 처음에는 주목을 받다가 최근에는 어떤 상황이냐면 저희가 AI가 계속 발전하고 있죠.
이게 반도체가 타는 게 아니라 그만큼 지금 수요가 많다는 얘기거든요.
그러니까 AI가 발전할수록 필요한 데이터들이 많아지는 거예요.
그러니까 HBM이라는 메모리 만으로 당연히 안 되고 디램도 더 필요하고 밑에 있는 랜드도 더 필요하고.
콘텍스트 데이터라고 해서 맥락 데이터.
심창민 님이 나 오늘 점심 뭐 먹을까 라고 했을 때 맵질이시죠?
맵질이기도 하고 맵당당이기도 하고.
맵당당이요.
어쨌든 저는 맵질이거든요.
저한테는 매운 갈비찜 같은 거를 추천하면 안 되는 거죠.
사람마다 달라야 되잖아요.
똑같은 거를 질문하더라도.
그러면 심창민 님의 맥락과 저의 맥락도 더 많이 계속 저장을 해 나가야 되니까.
지금은 HBM이 좋았던 것에서부터 디램도 좋고 랜드도 좋은 걸로 전체적으로 메모리 반도체 쪽으로 사이클이 확장됐다.
그래서 결론적으로 지금 말씀드린 대로 지금은 호황이죠.
그럼 이 호황이 언제쯤 끝날까라는 기미가 나오는지 안 나오는지 저희가 봐야 되는 거고.
그런 걸 보려면 앞으로 이런 거를 보시면 된다.
AI 기업들이 투자를 하고 있으니까 이 투자들을 잘 하고 있나?
두 번째로는 이제 공급.
왜냐하면 아까 수요와 공급이었잖아요.
저거는 필패예요.
공장 다 지었다는 소식.
그렇죠?
과거에 그래 왔죠.
공급이 확 늘 때마다 사이클이 주저앉았었기 때문에.
그래서 공급이라는 게 있는데 결론적으로는 기업들이 지금부터 투자를 해야 지어서 돌아가는 거니까.
그러면 지금 저희가 CAPEX라고 부르는 자본지출 계획에 들어가 있어야 되거든요.
이런 것들.
기업들이 지금 자본지출을 어떻게 계획하고 있는지.
그리고 마지막으로.
마지막에 말씀드렸던 HBM 반도체 관련.
이건 조금 삼성전자 관련된 이야기일 수 있는데.
뒤쳐진다라는 이야기들이 많이 있었고.
맞아요.
처음에는 따라섰는다라는 이야기가 많기 때문에.
그래서 이런 것들이 어떻게 되는지를 주목해보시면 조금 더 판단들을 해나가실 수 있지 않을까라고 생각을 하고 있고.
그럼 이런 것들 어디서 보느냐.
물론 뉴스 같은 데 찾아봐도 뉴스도 잘 나오긴 하고요.
기업들이 하는 얘기를 들어보면 좋잖아요.
그래서 실제로 기업들이 이런 어닝콜.
실적을 발표하고 자신들의 실적을 설명하는 컨퍼런스 콜이 있습니다.
이런 자리에서.
자신들의 관전 포인트라고 할 수 있는 부분들을 설명을 합니다.
얼마 안 남았네요.
이런 걸 들으면 어떻게 좋고 어떻게 안 좋아.
이런 걸 알려준다는 거잖아요.
그렇죠.
지금 상황이 어떻고.
질문에 대한 답변도 하고.
그러면 이거를 어닝콜을 보려면 어떻게 봐야 되는 거예요.
어떻게 보죠.
여기서부터 제가 설명드려도 될까요.
사실 이제 어닝콜에 관련해서는 본격적인 광고 시간입니다.
제가 라이브 전에 토스 정권에서 준비해 주신 어닝콜이라는 기능을 제가 사실은 사용해 봤어요.
오.
알게 모르게 쓰고 있더라고요.
알려줘요.
자꾸.
저는 원래 알려주는 건 줄 알았어요.
그래서 아 그렇구나.
그리고 심지어 나 같은 사람을 위해서 알려줘.
호재입니다.
악재입니다.
그것까지 알려줘.
긍정적임.
부정적임.
뭔 말인지 하나도 모르겠는데.
긍정적이라고.
긍정적인 게 계속 나니까 좋은 건가 보다.
이랬거든요.
그런데 알고 보니까 이 어닝콜이라는 게 그냥 막 흔히 있는 건 아니었던
것 같아요.
그래서 이거 시청자분들이 잘 모르실 수도 있는데.
설명을 한번 부탁드려도 될까요.
맞아요.
아까 선생님이 기업의 실적이라든가 이슈 이런 것들에 대해서 설명을
해주셨잖아요.
그런데 그 이후에도 뭔가 이런 업데이트를 계속 기업이 그래서 어떻게 지금
진행되고 있는지를 사실은 저희가 체크를 계속 해나가야 투자를 지속
할지 아니면 중단을 할지 그런 결정을 할 수 있을 텐데.
그렇죠.
그거를 확인할 수 있는 자리가 어닝콜이라고 보시면 될 것 같아요
.
어닝콜에 대해서 되게 좀 어려워 하시는데 어닝콜은 실적 발표 라이브
라고 보시면 돼요.
실시간으로 실적 발표를 이제 라이브 를 해주는 건데 기업이 분기마다
연간마다 이제 실적 발표를 합니다.
그런데 이제 숫자만 공시를 하는 게 아니라 일부 기업들 같은 경우에는
투자자들을 대상으로 설명을 하는 자리를 가져요.
우리가 왜 이 실적을 잘 만들어내 는지에 대해서 이유에 대해서 설명
을 해주고 그 이유에 대해서 설명 할 때 뭐 산업이라든가 시장 이러한
상황에 대해서도 같이 설명을 해주는 자리라고 보시면 될 것 같아요
.
그래서 투자자들한테는 굉장히 좋은 것 같아요.
유용한.
네.
맞아요.
그런데 그거를 이제 다 들을 순 옛날에는 없었나 봐요.
예전에는 이제 접근성이 되게 낮았다 라고 보시면 될 것 같아요.
그래서 특히나 해외 기업 같은 경우에는 어떠한 기업에 대해서 나는
실적 발표 어니콜 라이브를 한번 들어보고 싶어 라고 하면 어떻게
하시겠어요.
뭐 사정사정해서.
사정사정해서.
연락처 알아봐서 막 이렇게 해야 되겠죠.
그런데 이제 그게.
저는 한국에 사는 누구입니다.
어 맞아요.
그런데 지금 말씀하신 것처럼 접근 하기가 되게 어렵다라고 보시면
될 것 같아요.
이건 해외 기업뿐만 아니라 사실 국내 기업도 마찬가지라고 보시면
그런데 이제 토스증권에서는 앱에서 바로 보실 수 있다.
들을 수 있다.
보기 좋게.
네.
맞습니다.
그리고 실제로 들을 수 있게끔 원문도 남겨져 있죠.
다 이미 많이.
봤어요.
이용을 해보셨네요.
느낌이 좋았던 게 뭐냐면 담당자가 말을 하잖아요 기업의 담당자가.
ceo가 될 수도 있고 이렇게 말을 하면 현장감이 느껴져요.
뭔 말인지 모르겠는데 번역한 거만 보긴 하는데 일단 그 현장에서
말했던 게 녹음이 돼가지고 나오 니까 좋더라고요.
이게 좀 아무래도 이제 많은 분들이 사실 또 모르실 것 같아 가지고
저희 ppt 한번 보면서 제가 설명을 드려봐도 될까요.
알겠습니다.
네.
저희 토스증권을 들어오시면 여기 빨간색 보이시죠.
그래서 여기 이제 줄 세 개를 누르시면 될 거예요.
그래서 발견 탭을 누르시면 잠깐만 이거 하트 이거 뭐예요.
개인 그거요.
혜인 님 그 화면이에요.
아닙니다.
네.
깨알 같네.
아닙니다.
이건 제 화면이 아니고요.
네.
그렇고요.
그리고 여기 누르면 이제 인사이트 라는 게 보이실 거예요.
들어가 보시면 계속 얘기했던 어니콜 모아보기가 있을 거예요.
모아볼 수 있더라고요.
네.
맞아요.
그거 좋더라고요.
그리고 여기 있는 기업들의 수천 개의 기업들이 이제 어니콜들이
확인할 수 있다고 보시면 될 것 같아요.
그래서 심창민 님이 투자하시고 계신 여러 종목들 여러 기업들을 다
보실 수 있어요.
그렇게 확인하실 수 있다고 보시면 될 것 같고요.
그다음에 이제 어니콜이 끝난 후에 화면이라고 보시면 되는데 여기서
보면 제목을 한 문장으로 정리를 해 드리고 긍정 포인트 부정 포인트
까지 저희가 끝난 뒤에 그걸 요약 을 해 드린다라고 보시면 될 것
같아요.
그래서 아까 말씀하신 실제 실적 발표 현장의 음성을 여기서 바로
들으실 수 있습니다.
그러면 막 일론 머스크의 목소리라든지 이런 것들 들어볼 수 있는 거죠
.
맞습니다.
아까 그렇게 해서 이제 진입을 하셔도 되고요.
이렇게 어떤 특정 종목에 들어가서 종목 정보라는 탭이 있죠.
누르시면 이제 밑으로 내리시면 공시가 있어요.
기본적으로 어니콜은 어쨌든 실적 발표가 있어야 이제 그걸 기반으로
하는 라이브이기 때문에 모든 사람들이 다 확인할 수 있는 공시에서 확인
할 수 있다고 보시면 될 것 같고 어니콜도 여기서 확인할 수 있습니다.
그래서 누르시면 이렇게 아까 보시는 그 화면이 나타난다.
그래서 일론 머스크 목소리를 제가 들려드리려고 해요.
아.
네.
준비됐어요
들려드릴게요.
.
그리고 AI와 로보틱의 계속적인 성장에 따라
우리의 미래를 유니버셜 하이 인컴,
유니버셜 베이직 인컴으로 이끌고 싶습니다.
네, 이렇게 이제 굉장히 목소리 좋지 않나요?
목소리 좋고, 한상우님 좀 해석을 해주신다면?
네, 해석해주세요.
긍정적이다.
이렇게 저희가 실시간으로 이거를 다 전사를 해요.
문단 요약을 이렇게 제공한다라고 보시면 될 것 같고요.
한글을 누르면 이렇게 한글로 다 이제 실시간으로
보실 수 있다라고 보시면 될 것 같아요.
아, 저거 좋아요.
언제 쓰냐면은 미장할 때 원화로 보기로 하거든요, 저는.
그래서 원화로 보기 하면은 저는 맨날 얼마에 샀다 할 때
원화로 계산하는데 다 달러로 얘기하더라고요.
왜 자꾸 달러로 얘기하는 거예요? 헷갈리게.
원화로 얘기해야 편하지 않아요?
각자의 원화 시점이 다르니까.
각자가 또 니즈가 다르다 보니까.
자꾸 달러 얘기를 하더라고요, 헷갈리게.
아무튼 여기 또 영어로 했던 거를 실시간으로 한글로 번역할 수 있다.
실시간 스크립트 이거 좋네.
그래서 여기서 이제 좋아요,
시원하게,
좋아요, 시원하게,
이거에 대해서 이렇게 반응도 누를 수 있고요.
저희가 PRP 모드도 제공이 되기 때문에
밖으로 나가셔서 차트랑 같이 보시면서 이거를 띄우면서 보실 수도 있다라고 보시면 될 것 같아요.
그러니까 이게 토스증권은 편의성이 참 좋은 것 같아요.
제가 쓰면서도 좀 느끼는 거예요.
그리고 사실은 이제 해외 기업 같은 경우에는
어닝콜이 되게 진행되는 시간이 새벽이라든가 아니면 저녁이라서
이걸 라이브 시간대에 대한 꼭꼭 이거 들어야 돼?
약간 부담이 사실 있을 수 있어요.
그래서 많은 분들이 이거에 대해서 좀 어려워하시는데
끝나고 나서 저희가 AI 분석 다 해드린다라고 말씀드리죠.
저는 사실 이렇게 모아서 보는 거는
이번에 광고가 잡혀있다고 해서 좀 이제 보면서 이제 알았고
근데 이거 기능이 좋더라고요.
딱 어닝콜만 모아서 볼 수 있다는 거.
그렇죠. 그렇죠.
이것도 굉장히 깔끔한 것 같고
그것도 심지어 못 알아들을까 봐
분석까지 하나하나 분해해가지고
밀전병으로 만들어서 싹 싸가지고 입에 넣어주니까 얼마나 좋습니까.
근데 많은 사람들이 제가 이렇게 말씀을 드려도 어려워하세요.
전문 연구도 많고 실적 수치도 어렵고 재무제표 모르겠어요.
그럼에도 불구하고
저는 이렇게 말씀드리고 싶어요.
필링이 중요하다.
아 느낌. 현장 분위기.
네. 그렇죠. 현장 분위기.
왜냐하면 주식시장은 기업의 경영진들이 얼마나 자신감에 차서
이 실적에 대해서 설명을 하는지
아니면 뭔가 좀 방어적으로 좀 소극적으로 말하는지
이런 것까지 캐치를 하려고 해요.
그거에 따라서 주가가 굉장히 요동치고요.
그래서 그런 부분들이 사실 어닝콜 스크립트라든가 그런 거에서 나타나고
그래서 이 어닝콜에서는 올해 얼마나 벌 건지에 대해서 가이던스도 제시를 하고요.
그거 기준으로 우리가 항상 그럼 실적을 체크하면 되는 거죠.
어? 이때 뭐 이 정도 번다고 했는데 이번에 못 맞췄네?
이 정도 예상됐다라고 하는데 더 실적을 냈네?
이런 거를 이제 판단할 수 있는 되게 좋은 자리라고 보시면 될 것 같아요.
사실 그냥 심심해서 듣는 사람들 많잖아요.
그렇죠. 노수를 좋잖아요.
신창민 유튜브 듣느니 이거 듣는 게 나은 것 같아.
왜냐하면 도움이 되잖아요.
신창민 유튜브는 머리에 남는 게 없잖아요.
쉴 수 있잖아요.
이렇게 좋은 또 콘텐츠가 있잖아요.
재밌고.
아 그래요?
어 그럼요.
그럼요.
그럼 어닝콜보다 더 귀해요 그러면?
어닝콜만큼 귀하다.
아 그래?
어닝콜만큼.
아 그렇구나.
그럼 알겠습니다.
그리고 이제 말씀드리고 싶은 부분 중에 하나가
실적 발표 전에도 사람들끼리 관전 포인트가 뭔지
저희가 또 그런 것도 제공을 하고 있습니다.
그래서
어? 6개 신규 공장 저거 아 최악이야.
그렇죠?
제가 아까 배웠잖아요.
공장 지으면 이거 어? 공급 과잉 돼가지고 떨어지잖아.
이거 안 돼 안 돼 이거 뭐야.
근데 이제 지금까지는 저희가 해외 기업 어닝콜만 사실 제공을 하고 있었는데
국내 기업도 이제 제공을 하게 됩니다.
국내가 근데 더 어려워요?
그 어닝콜 그거 모으기가?
국내 기업들은 사실은 공개적으로 어닝콜을 제공을 하고 있진 않고요.
여전히 많은 기업들이 비공개로 좀 진행을 하는 경우가 많다라고 보시면 될 것 같아요.
비공개면 그러면 어떻게 내부 사람들만
이렇게 사원인과치 애널리스트분들 아니면 기관 투자자분들
이런 분들만 이제 모시고 사실 진행을 하는 경우가 사실 많아요.
그래서 내가 주식 투자를 잘 못했네.
왜 나는 안 들려주는 거야.
왜 들으실 때 저 안 불렀어요?
그래서 혜인님이.
그렇죠.
그래서
저희의
슬로건이 투자의 힘을 모두에게라는 슬로건을 저희 회사는 가지고 있어요.
아 있어요?
네네네.
그래서 그 슬로건 사이에 되게 많은 접근성을 훨씬 더 높여드리기 위해서
이런 제품들과 서비스를 제공한다라고.
근데 광고를 떠나서 방향성이 되게 딱 맞는다는 느낌이 드네요.
왜냐면 제가 사용했을 때 되게 편하다는 느낌이 들었는데
슬로건 자체가 그거랑 딱 부합한다면
맞는 방향으로 뭔가 가고 있다는 거니까.
맞아요. 맞아요.
그러면 이제 국내도 이제 서비스를 이제 한다?
맞습니다.
다는 아니죠?
왜냐면 뭐 비공개가 있다면서요.
네. 여전히 많기 때문에.
전 의외였어요. 국내가 아무래도 먼저 하고 해외가 됐을 줄 알았는데
해외가 오히려 그런 게 좀 더 많이 공개가 됐고.
맞아요. 맞아요.
그럼 왜 공개를 안 해요? 한국은?
심창민님이 좀 이렇게 힘 좀 실어주세요.
아 그래요?
왜 공개 안 합니까? 공개해주세요.
저도 주식으로 돈 벌고 싶어요.
해주세요. 해주세요.
공개 많이 해주세요.
그러면 공개를 좀 할까요? 다른 기업들이?
해줬으면 좋겠네요.
공개한 데는 우리가 볼 수가 있다.
맞습니다.
똑같이 이거.
네. 그리고 저 소스 좀.
그런 건에서는 그걸 한 눈에 다 그러니까 한 번에 볼 수가 있죠.
이 기업 들어갔다가 저 기업 들어갔다가 이렇게 보실 수 있다라는 장점이 있죠.
그러니까 모아보기가 괜찮은 거 같아요.
사전 신청 막 이런 것도 필요 없고요.
언제나 들어오셔서 보실 수 있다.
근데 이제 관련 뉴스가 제가 옛날부터 계속 보는데 뉴스가 되게 많을 거 아니에요.
어떤 기준으로 추리는지도 좀 궁금했어요.
왜냐면 되게 많을 텐데.
그거 관련해서는 앱에 보시면 밑에서 이제 설명을 하고 있긴 합니다.
어떠한 기준으로 저희가 이제 뉴스를 제공하는지에 대해서.
그런 세세한 것들도 저희가.
다 앱에서 확인하실 수 있어요.
아 알겠습니다.
확실히 여러분들이 이제 이번 시간에 아셔야 될 거는 토스증권의 어닝콜을 모아서 볼 수 있는 편리한 기능이 있으니까.
관심 있으면 한 번 이용해 보시라는 뭐 이런 내용입니다.
맞습니다.
자 광고는 이제 끝났고요.
바로 마무리할 시간입니다.
사실은 주식 투자나 뭐 이런 금융 쪽 그렇게까지 궁금증이 많을 거라고는 생각을 못 했어요.
그냥 아 어떻게 해야 돈을 벌까.
이런 생각이 좀 많았던 거 같았는데.
말씀을 나누다 보니까 계속 궁금한 게 생기긴 해요.
지금 사실 너무 흐름을 끊을까 봐 질문을 안 드린 것도 있어요.
너무 엉뚱깽뚱한 소리라 가지고.
그래서 다음에 한 번 또 기회가 되면 또 한 번 여쭤보고 싶은 그런 생각도 좀 듭니다.
너무 좋아요.
소감 한 말씀 또 들어보도록 하겠습니다.
일단 생각보다 너무 많이 아셔 가지고 놀랐고.
오늘 너무 긴장되지만 즐거운 시간이었습니다.
그리고 짤 있잖아요.
네.
모아서 좀 보내주세요.
아 모른다더라고요.
저 쓰게.
너무 잘 깔끔하게 깍두기처럼 잘 했어요.
혜인님도 소감 한 말씀.
아 네.
꼭 말씀드리고 싶은 게
저희 토스 정권의 많은 직원분들, 동료분들이 지금도 아마 지켜보시고 계실 것 같아요.
근데 제가 이제 대표에서 이렇게 나오긴 했지만
그분들한테도 정말 수고 많으시고 고생 많으시다라는 말씀 여기서 꼭 드리고 싶고.
그리고 이렇게 또 침창민 님과 라이브를 진행하게 돼서 되게 가문의 영광이다.
이렇게 생각하고 싶어요.
그래서 저희 어머니도 아마 보고 계실 텐데.
네. 아유 감사합니다.
네네네.
아 근데 그 동료들 얘기를 하시는 거 보면은 돈도 가신가 봐요.
팀 내 분위기가 좋아요?
저희가 최고의 복지는 동료라는 말이에요.
최복동.
그만큼 좋은 동료들.
좋은 동료들과 같이 일하고.
자전거 도둑 아니에요?
아 아니에요. 최복동.
최복동.
네.
자 그러면 이제 마무리할 시간이고요.
삼성전자 어닝콜 아까 말씀드린 것처럼 4월 30일 오전 10시에 들어보실 수 있습니다.
토스 증권 앱에서 간편하게 들으실 수 있습니다.
스크립트도 이제 편하게 이제 보실 수 있고요.
덕분에 오늘 너무 즐거운 시간 보냈습니다.
네.
토스 증권 많은 사랑 부탁드리고요.
저희는 이만 물러가보도록 하겠습니다.
여러분들 투자는 결국 본인들의 선택입니다.
그렇기 때문에 공부를 스스로 해야 돼요.
공부 안 하면 어떻게 되는지 알아요?
저처럼 돼요.
침착맨처럼 됩니다.
삼성전자 7만원에 팔고 21만원에 사는 그런 사람입니다.
저도 지금부터 계속 공부를 꾸준히 할 생각입니다.
자 그러면 가보겠습니다.
안녕히 계십시오.